a group of diplomats from 15 nations
including the u.s. is on a two-day visit
to indian-administered Kashmir it's the
first time that foreign diplomats have
been invited by the Indian government to
assess the situation after New Delhi
revoked the region's autonomy last
August half sir Cantwell is assistant
professor of South Asian history at
Lafayette College she joins us now via
Skype from the US state of New Jersey
good to have you with us how credible is
this visit this is actually not a
credible visit at all I see it as a
scripted propaganda tour the Modi
government knows that it has received
some international condemnation of what
it's done to push Mead in the past five
months the communication clamped down
massive detentions and arrests and other
human rights violations and it's also
important to note that there is actually
a house resolution in the US Congress
745 that has received bipartisan support
and I think their intention the
government's intention is to create an
optics of normalcy to ensure that there
is no further international action on
what India is doing English food the
EU's ambassador is not part of of this
delegation what are we to make of that I
think that was a good step that the EU
tip took because it understood that this
was a scripted tour and I think the
nature of the tour just I just drive
reports that basically the delegation
was brought in to cush made in the late
morning today they were directly taken
in a huge motorcade to the army
headquarters where they were given a
security briefing and then they were
again taken to another location where
they met with a hand-picked group of
politicians and journalists that
appraised them of the situation they
were not allowed to meet with the common
people they were not allowed to meet
with the pro-freedom leadership so I
think for the EU and even though they
said that they did not go because they
were not gonna have access to met with
the former chief ministers that are
currently under detention and I think
it's really important to push them have
them push the Indian government to meet
Koosh Metis on the ground and hear from
them what's happening and not
politicians that are basically being put
in place as kind of a new front
Englishman yeah as you said these this
delegation has been unable to meet
prominent Kashmiri politicians who at
the moment are under detention are they
yes they are under detention three
former Chief Minister's are under
detention but I think it's important for
people to recognize that when it comes
to understanding the pulse on the ground
what committees feel think and want for
their future these politicians don't
represent their aspirations they've
always served New Delhi's interests
they've been in client regimes and they
had no legitimacy on the ground and once
New Delhi makes use of them and doesn't
need them anymore they're discarded so I
think again it's really important for
this delegation to meet or any future
delegations to meet people on the ground
especially the pro-freedom leadership
that has been under detention well
before August 5th good - totally I have
so many thanks indeed to have seconds
well there